القرار اتخذ والاعلان اعلن رسميا ولكنه
سيسري خلال 30 يوم يقول مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي بانه لمنح الوقت للتقليل
من اثار هذا القرار على الشعب ال اليمني
وهناك ايضا في المقابل تصريحات اخرى لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ماذا
تابعتم في هذا الاطار محمد
العلمي نعم اشار وزير الخارج الامريكي
الذي يشارك في منتدى دافوس الى ان القرار
الجديد سيدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد 30 يوما
لاتخاذ كل الاجراءات الضروريه للحيلوله
دون ان يؤثر القرار على الشعب
اليمني لانه حسب ما صرح به ايضا مسؤولون
امريكيون امس
بان الشحنات التجاريه الى الموانئ اليمنيه
التي تتضمن ادويه او او معدات غذائيه او
اي شيء في المجال الاغاثي لن يشملها هذا
القرار الذي يبدو انه استدراك لما حصل في
القرار او ادراج الجماعه في يناير 2021 من
طرف الحكومه الامريكيه السابقه في عهد
ترامب ولحول دون تكرار ذلك تم التنصيص
تحديدا على استثناء المواد الاغاثه
والمواد الانسانيه وال والغذاء وغيرها من
هذا القرار الذي لن يدخل حيث تنفيذ مره
اخرى الا بعد 30 يوما من هذه الساعه التي
تم الاعلان فيها رسميا على اعاده ادراج
جماعه انصار الله الحوثييين في قائمه
المنظمه الاعرابيه الدوليه ابقى معنا